[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIRAT PANDYA: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining us.
My name is Kirat Pandya.
I'm a technical lead on
partner engineering for machine
learning at Google Cloud.
And the topic we're
going to cover today
is, how do you automate
invoice management, right?
Well, every business
practically has
invoices that they're either
paying or sending out,
and these are pieces of
paper, and how do you automate
that using machine learning?
All right, so, going
back to the roots--
why are we here?
What is the goal?
The goal at the end of
the day-- for Google,
here-- is to democratize AI.
We want to take all
these bleeding edge
innovations in
artificial intelligence
that our research
teams at Google Brain
are coming up with
and making them
available to your businesses.
To make it so that
instead of needing
one of the thousands of
data scientists globally,
one of the millions
of developers
globally can then use
the same technologies.
That's the goal here.
And with that in
mind, the question
we have to ask ourselves is--
given the limited resources
we have-- every organization,
at the end, has
limited resources--
how do we target our
resources to get the most
ROI for everyone involved?
Not just us-- our
customers, our partners.
And what that leads us to is the
question of unstructured data.
So, one of the very sort
of interesting pieces
of statistics or whatever that
a lot of people don't realize
is that upwards of
90% of enterprise data
is unstructured.
It's all those emails.
It's all those word documents.
It's all those text files.
It's all those PDFs
sitting in accounting.
That's all unstructured data.
And the challenge
with unstructured data
is not only is it
abundant, it's hard.
You think of structured data,
you think of a database, right?
The average CTO goes, oh, yeah--
I have "XYZ" amount of
petabytes in databases,
and the way you
access that is easy.
You write a bunch
of SQL queries.
Or there's a standard
ecosystem that everybody
reaches for of tools.
But if I gave you a chunk of
unstructured data and say,
go get me answers--
there's no clear answer.
There is no standard set of
tools that you're going to use.
Someone's going
to reach for, you
know, regular expressions
or some of those things.
But what we're doing
here now is applying ML.
And the idea is that
machine learning
has a very clear
path to making sense
of unstructured,
massive volumes of data.
Part two of the story is that
transformation's coming, right?
Businesses used to
be run like this.
This is what we're moving to.
And you should have started
your journey a while ago,
but if you haven't,
that's still OK.
You can still do it now.
And the underlying theme
here is the announcements
you saw around AutoML--
all these cutting
edge technologies--
you can apply them
to your business--
your existing business process--
as you are on this
journey of transformation.
So, the announcement
this morning
was about Iron Mountain
and our partnership there.
And what are we doing here?
The goal is to advance automated
document understanding.
We're working with
Iron Mountain to--
with their customers'
permission-- digitize data
and derive
understanding from it.
So all that dark data that's
sitting stored away from years
of records-- literally
the US corporate history
of the Fortune 1000--
extracting valuable--
today-- dark data
using machine learning.
But, as all these
presentations go--
the ML guy comes
on stage and goes
on about how ML
is going to change
the world in the future--
we'll get there.
That's true.
But let's talk
about here and now.
How can you use
the tools we talked
about this morning and all day
today and throughout Next--
AutoML and machine vision to
automate an existing process?
So this is about here and now.
This is something that
you can start using today.
So, as one of the scenarios in
the thousands we could tackle
with how businesses deal with
documents, the one that seems
to impact the most number
of businesses is, hey,
I buy stuff as a part
of doing business.
I owe people money.
Or I sell stuff and
people owe me money.
And these documents
need to be processed.
We've been doing
that since 1860.
This is an actual invoice from
1860, and this is a modern one.
Nothing's really changed.
And the reason it hasn't
changed is the computer science
behind making a
protocol packet to have
two computers talk about,
"Hey, you owe me X" is easy.
But there are too many players.
The structure of that packet
cannot be agreed upon.
So what we've done is we've
sort of fallen back to,
well we have accounts
receiving, and the invoice team
has people that look at it
and approve it and it's a--
you know, it's a human
intervention process.
So let's change that.
So what does it mean to do
document understanding--
at 10,000 feet.
The thing people usually
jump to is, oh this is OCR.
This is not just OCR.
OCR is Optical
Character Recognition.
Literally.
The "Hello World" of machine
learning for any new learning
data scientist is a
data set called MNIST.
And this data set is
understanding characters.
It's literally the "Hello
World" of the industry.
What we're talking about here is
going from that extracted text
to recreating the structure that
is apparent to a human that's
reading the document--
recreating that structure
and then putting it
into a system that
manages structured
data, and it's
part of a business process.
That is truly document
understanding.
And at 10,000 feet,
it's these three steps.
And where OCR is literally
is just step one.
OK so let's talk about
each of the pieces.
Step one-- you extract the text.
So Google has the
Cloud Vision API.
This API solves computer
vision challenges and problems
that are general in nature.
It's not going to identify
my business' widget
A versus widget
B. But if you want
to identify a ship
versus a boat,
it can do that because
this is a general problem.
It impacts everything.
This is the
technology that backs
Google's efforts in search.
Part of this offering is
an offering to do OCR.
So, when you use
Google search, we're
not just looking at the
metadata around the search.
We're looking into the images
to find irrelevant-- images.
So the technology that
powers that is also what
powers the Vision API to do OCR.
So, OK-- we have step
one-- we give it an image.
It gives us the text.
Part two of this is that the
pricing here is a game changer.
I'll let this slide speak
for itself, honestly,
but it's pennies on the dollar.
And one of the key friction
points in business--
there's a reason it's hard
to structure businesses
on a $1 transaction because
the transaction fee completely
kills any margin you have.
So as you're trying to reduce
your costs of transactions--
reduce the friction
of transactions--
this becomes very important.
So this basically makes the
costs of transactions pennies
on the dollar.
All right.
Step two.
So we got the text
out of the document.
Now we've got to restructure it.
We said we're going to
apply machine learning.
That's great.
Now you're going to
need a data scientist.
And this person will go away
for six months, eight months
and come back with a model.
In that period, you will have
spent lots and lots of money,
lots and lots of time, lots
and lots of engineering,
and lots and lots of
organizational focus
on solving this problem
where each of these
is a very complex
problem in itself
that engineers specialize in.
So we go back to our
first principles.
First principles
are that's not OK.
We need to make the technology
available and accessible
to every developer.
So we have AutoML.
The idea behind AutoML is that
all of this becomes one click.
It becomes one API call.
You give it the data.
You give it the data set.
And you tell it, go train.
And in a couple of hours
it comes back to you
with a model that will
have best-in-class accuracy
and then it gives you, again,
a one API call way to say,
go host this in a
scalable way for me
so that I can just
make requests to it
and I don't have to
worry about "Well,
I need the right infrastructure
to do low-latency inference
on my model--" None of that.
You don't have to
worry about it.
You just tell us, and
we host it for you.
So what does AutoML
Vision do in this case?
AutoML Vision is, what's in the
parlance, called a classifier.
It builds you a classifier.
You give it classes
of training data
that say, hey, here's a bunch
of pictures of handbags, shoes,
and hats, and you train it.
And then at the
end of the day, it
gives you a model that when you
give it a picture of a shoe--
even one it hasn't seen
before, but it's a shoe.
A human would
recognize the shoe.
It'll tell you this is a shoe.
In concept, pretty
straightforward.
In implementation billions
of dollars of research.
So I said it's going
to give you one
of the best in class models.
AutoML produces
more accurate models
with fewer parameters than
practically all the other
what I would call benchmark
vision models today.
So you've got Inception V4.
You've got ResNet-152,
Reznext 101, VGG-16,
and you can see the red
line with AutoML on top
where, depending on how
much time and energy spent
on training it, you get more
and more accuracy with fewer
and fewer parameters.
Now, why does this matter?
This matters because--
I know what you're thinking.
But, well if Google is going to
do it, then it doesn't matter.
It matters in latency
and compute costs--
that inference time.
So once the model
is built, you're
going to make hundreds of
thousands of requests over time
against it.
So if a model has 10%
more parameters in it,
you're doing 10% more compute
across hundreds and thousands
of requests.
So this is important.
The other reason
it's important--
so that was sort of this axis--
the other reason it's
important-- this axis--
is that if you get it wrong,
either your business process
has a problem down the line.
Or now you have to employ the
person that you've freed up
to do a better task than just
scanning an invoice is now
back in the loop to make sure
that the computer doesn't
screw up.
So that's not OK, too.
Hence, this is important.
So a little bit of-- sort
of, technical [INAUDIBLE]
about AutoML.
So, the technology
powering AutoML
is called learn to learn, where
we've got a neural network that
is effectively watching
the model being built
for you being trained
and tweaking the training
process as it goes.
So effectively-- sounds
like a buzzword--
I get it.
But it's literally a model
building another model,
is what's going on.
And that's called
learning to learn.
And then, along with
that, we're doing
large-scale
hyperparameter tuning
to give you that super
accurate model without you
having to do any work.
If you want to discuss
the internals of this,
I'll be here after, too.
We can geek out.
So, next up-- so we got the
piece for extracting the text.
We got the piece
for well, vaguely--
we have this thing
that does a classifier.
There are two tools
in our vision box.
How do we put this all together?
I promise that the solution
here would plug into an existing
business process where you're
not throwing everything away.
It's connecting to something
real that you're using today.
So what I'd like to do is
invite one of our partners up.
One of the ways that Google
makes these things real
is we work with our partners,
and our partners really
understand how each business
is special in its own way.
Google builds the surgeon's
toolset, if you will,
to stretch an analogy.
And then our partners
are the surgeons
who take those tool sets and do
the surgeries-- make it real.
And so in that vein, I'd like
to invite Chandra from Deloitte
to come and talk to us about how
they put these things together
to solve the invoice
management problem.
CHANDRA MAHALE: Thank you.
KIRAT PANDYA: Chandra.
CHANDRA MAHALE: Yeah.
Thank you, Kirat.
Can you hear me OK?
OK, good.
So, amazing technology, right?
Machine learning now
with a new announcement
of AutoML from [INAUDIBLE]
you must have heard yesterday.
So why does Google
need partners?
Deloitte, as a
system integrator--
we are very close
to the business.
We understand each industry.
We understand the different
business challenges
in every line of business,
and we take this technology
and then we implement
solutions which
are very relevant for every
company, every industry,
every business process.
And Deloitte has been working
with Google for multiple years
now, whether it's in the form
of infrastructure as a service,
whether it's in the form of
analytics using BigQuery,
whether it's in the
form of AppSense
for creating a new marketing
platform for our customers
to get more insights,
and obviously AutoML.
Before AutoML was announced,
it was available to us
as a partner in a beta form, but
we realized the power of ML--
just ML without AutoML--
very early on.
And we realized that
many of our customers
can leverage a
true benefit which
is extremely cost-effective.
It can be implemented
in Agile manner,
not wait for six months or
a year to see the value.
So we started working with
Google's machine learning
team and the infrastructure
team to develop this solution.
So let me walk you through it.
So now every company,
whether you do services,
whether you
manufacturer goods, you
have to process invoices to
pay your vendors on time.
Its part of your--
and every vendor
is unique because they all
have their own branding.
They have a different
structure, a different layout.
So we need to be able
to extract the invoice--
get the business data, whether
it's a model number, quantity,
amount, address-- you want to
make sure it goes to the right
address--
so all this business
information,
which is in different
format for every vendor,
has to be extracted in
a very accurate form
and before a financial
document is created.
So a very crucial
business process.
And let me share with you--
until now, companies,
whether it's
a mid-size company or
large-size companies,
spend millions of dollars with
a commercial off-the-shelf
solution from different vendors
to do the vendor invoice
management, which easily cost
anywhere from $2 to $4 million
just from licensing.
Now, on top of that, add a
few months of implementation,
testing with your ERP.
Now every time ERP goes
through a software change,
you again have to go back
to that invoice management
solution.
Do some testing.
Do some remediation.
Every time a new vendor is
incorporated to your business,
you have to go through the
programming all over again
because they have a
completely different logo,
completely different format.
So it's a very,
very slow process.
A very, very
expensive processes.
And it does not leverage any
benefits of cloud computing
and machine learning.
And plus-- on top
of all of this--
it has a very high sunk cost.
Whether you use all the features
of your invoice management
solution or not, you
have to buy all of it.
And you have to spend
millions of dollars upfront.
So that is why we
developed this solution.
Deloitte has developed
this, prepared this solution
for automated invoice management
for your S/4HANA ERP system.
So S/4HANA is SAP's large
enterprise business planning
solution, we have
developed this up
because we know SAP
S/4HANA in detail.
We understand the
business processes,
so it's going to help
us, obviously, automate
your invoice management.
It's going to make
it more efficient.
Its going to be a much faster
lifecycle from a solution
perspective to scan
invoices, post it
to the business documents, and,
obviously, adapt it as you go.
So let's walk through
a little bit in detail
about the different
components that are involved.
So, as you see-- as you
heard from Kirat, obviously
machine learning is a
very crucial component
along with the Vision API.
Those are the building blocks
of scanning the invoice
to make sure we
extract the right data.
So our developers,
who are very well
informed about machine learning
and the coding required-- so,
we develop our code around
these two technologies.
Then it has cloud storage
to store these invoices
because every customer
scans roughly--
you know, anywhere
from a few thousand
to several hundred
thousand invoices
on a monthly or quarterly basis.
A lot of money right?
And you do it most of
the time in a batch mode,
for most customers.
And the room for
error is very small
because you don't want to get
an invoice inaccurately scanned
which could be for thousands
of dollars to a wrong vendor.
So there is a lot
of money at stake.
It's a real business problem.
So cloud storage helps us
to store all those invoices
for audit compliance perspective
for a much longer period
at a very, very low cost.
And, plus, it's available
everywhere in the world
as long as you have a
cell phone or a laptop.
And obviously, S/4HANA, which
is your business system,
will take that invoice and then
post it for financial document.
So now I'm going
to invite Sudha,
who is my colleague
who's going to decompose
this architecture for you.
Help you through each
and every process.
Step by step, how do
we scan the invoice?
How do we get the OCR data?
How does the AP clerk
get to review that data,
and then post it in SAP?
So, Sudar, over to you.
SUDHA KARRI: Thank you, Chandra.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Sudha Karri.
I am the global
SAP S/4HANA Center
of Excellence lead at
Deloitte, and we've
been working very
closely with Google
on building the solution.
So I wanted to take
it a step further,
get into the real
details, and help
you understand what
the solution is
and what components
involved, details [INAUDIBLE]
ordered, and followed by a demo.
So let's just kind
of get started.
So there are essentially
three steps--
three main steps--
for the solution.
The step number one is
uploading an invoice.
It's kind of obvious, right?
So you have your
invoices which need
to be scanned and uploaded.
One important information
for you to note here
is that the invoices
that are uploaded
are stored in Google Cloud
Storage, which is obviously
running on Google
Cloud Platform.
And the scanning of
invoices can either
be done from your laptop,
mobile phone, or any device.
So all those capabilities
are built in.
Now, the third important
thing for you to know
is when you talk about
invoice management,
you're obviously talking volume.
So any corporate
customer would have
ten of thousands of invoices
that get uploaded every day.
So that's where the upload
functionality comes in.
Now, the next important part
is the intelligent extraction
of these invoices.
So you have got these invoices
which are uploaded and ready.
How do you actually understand
the information there?
And there are again three
steps to this intelligent text
extraction.
Step number one is
using the Vision API
to actually extract the
detail from the invoice.
So, for that they are
using Google's machine
learning Vision API.
Extremely capable
API tool there.
We have seen it work with
different kinds of invoices.
I mean, invoices often
have scribbled text--
text manually written.
All those kind of invoices
also work extremely well
with the Vision API.
Then the next component is now
you have extracted the details.
How do you know what
information is where?
So for that, we have
YAML config which
comes into play, which
helps us in understanding
what information is
read in the invoice.
So that's step number two.
Now the third thing is you
have extracted the information.
How do you know that
this particular invoice
is a template from
a particular vendor.
How do you connect this?
That's where the third
component, which is AutoML,
comes in.
And then we developed
the solution--
we've been developing that
over a period of time.
We had used traditional ML
and we also used AutoML.
And once we started
using AutoML,
we actually saw that there was
a good increase in confidence
per sent page.
So when I show you
the demo, you'd
actually get a peek at it.
But with AutoML, we were really
able to enhance the solution.
So the combination of
these three-- extraction
of the solution and
then classification
of the solution-- you're
actually able to do
take this unstructured
data and convert
into more structured data.
Now the third
component here is-- now
we have extracted the invoice.
We have all the information.
This information
is posted into SAP.
And it's not just plain
posting of invoice
that I'm talking about.
There are also business
rules, validations,
and checks that come into
the picture and work close
to make sure that the data
that is getting uploaded
is, in fact, accurate
and is business-ready.
So those are really
the three components
which come into play
in this whole process.
So I wanted to get you guys
a little bit of a visual feel
of how this is happening.
So what you see
in the background
is how the text
extraction is working.
This is where the
Vision API is looking
at the components of
the invoice and then is
extracting all the information
which is there then invoiced.
Different blocks, as
you can see over here.
OK, so once the
extraction is done,
then YAML config
comes in the picture.
This is a really user friendly--
I would say easy to understand--
where you would look at the
invoice and you're able to see
what information is
where in the invoice.
Now, let's get to
the third part,
which is the cool part, which
is now you have extracted
the information in the invoice.
How are you actually
going to identify
that this information
belongs to--
corresponds to this
particular template.
And that's when AutoML comes in.
So as you can see here, there
are three different invoices.
share a completely
different format
from three different vendors.
So all this information
is getting fed into AutoML
and when a new
invoice comes in, you
are able to identify that
this invoice corresponds
to this particular template.
So that's how the
whole thing is working.
We have trained the model with
multiple invoices and really
good results that
we are able to see .
And that's what I
wanted to show you
once we get into the demo mode.
I think that's pretty much it.
Let's quickly
switch to the demo.
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
OK so let me
introduce this screen
a little bit to those of you who
are not very familiar with SAP.
Actually, a quick show of
hands-- how many of you
have used SAP?
Are SAP customers?
You know, have interacted or
that have worked with SAP?
OK.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That gives me an idea.
So this is-- for those
of you who do not know--
this is called SAP Fiori tiles.
These tiles are
essentially called
as-- this is SAP's
new user interface,
and the tiles are
called the Fiori tiles.
Really convenient, easy to use.
And we have developed
this user interface
using SAP's Cloud Platform.
So what you see,
essentially, here
is SAP Cloud Platform there.
So the step number
one that we have here
is scanning of invoice,
like how I explained.
So we take these
invoices, we scan them.
The demo would show you the
invoices in online mode,
but this can very
well be batched
when we're using tens and
thousands of invoices.
So these are the
different components.
We have got the scanned
invoice, and I also
wanted you to look at
the Google Cloud Storage
where this invoice
actually gets stored.
OK.
So here is a look at
that why is that we
actually going to upload.
So I'm going to
take one invoice,
we'll take it all
the way through,
then I can show you
another invoice,
which is in a completely
different format as well.
So take the invoice--
a more clear look at it.
So all the information is there.
We got the item details.
So, we get into the
Cloud Platform screen--
a quick button there--
which we click on and we
select the invoice and it's
all successfully uploaded.
So once this is uploaded,
you can actually
go to the cloud
platforms and you
should be able to look
at the invoice as well.
So this is what--
this is where it
is all day noises are going
and sitting in the background.
Next is a viewing
off scanned invoices.
OK I want to pause here.
I'm going to explain you
this screen a little bit.
So what just happened
is, we had the invoice
which we scanned there and put
it in Google Cloud Storage.
Now, in the lookup invoice
screen that invoice shows up.
And what you're seeing over here
is the extracted information
from the invoice.
The third screen as I
play is the actual image
of the invoice.
So once we click on
the Next button--
let me just--
Yeah.
So this is the header
and detail of invoice.
There you see the
confidence percentage, 95%,
which quickly flashed there.
That actually shows
the improved percentage
that we to got once we
started using AutoML.
So, this is the invoice
that we scanned.
All information
there and let me just
pause over here so we
can actually absorb
this information completely.
The left was invoice
that got uploaded,
and to its right is the actual
invoice that was uploaded.
And what you see here
are in the middle
is the information that got
extracted from this invoice
and is now right over here.
So this is the three
step very, very,
I would say intuitive
user interface.
Another important one I
want to really emphasize
is I'm showing you this whole
entire thing in online mode.
But when you are dealing with
tens and thousands of invoices
you would actually batch this.
So this is not--
I mean you wouldn't really
be clicking on a submit
when processing these invoices.
What you would
essentially do is,
we have the confidence
percentages, the thresholds,
which you can set.
For example, you can say that
anything over 93%, or 95%,
whatever you may, all those
invoices would go through.
Automatically If it's less
than that, then potentially
you can manually look
at those invoices.
So those kind of
thresholds and parameters
can be sent to do make this a
much more automated process.
So the PO information, the
details are kind of there.
That's the key.
Yeah, once we come back
in, the item information--
the confidence percentage,
again, really good there.
We click on Submit.
So here is what happens as
soon as you click on Submit.
I want to pause
here and kind of--
so this is the invoice--
the number of the invoice
which actually posted in SAP.
So this invoice is immediately
going in and posting in SAP.
So essentially what we do is--
the screen that you saw
previously is the out-of-box
SAP app--
Fiori app which is provided
for supplier invoices.
So the invoice that we
just created automatically
got posted in SAP.
So getting to the
screen and looking
at this particular invoice--
let me continue.
So the invoice which we
copied and pasted there--
you see the document
is already posted.
We can get into SAP.
You can look at the invoice--
the item details, tax, payment--
everything got populated,
and even the attachment
is also there.
So this is the
invoice, as you recall,
is what we had uploaded.
Yep.
OK.
So I know that--
yeah.
So the previous screen that we
saw was a SAP S4/HANA screen.
I know that many of you
are ECC customers as well.
So we also wanted to show
this, that the same thing--
the invoice that is created
is posted in the back-end
as well, to get you to
see how the ECC user
interfaces or the back-end
GUI would look like.
The same invoice--
we put that in.
And you are able to get in into
that-- and same information,
you see, in the back-end--
SAP back-end, too.
The item details--
everything accurate--
you have the vendor
details as well.
And then now we're able
to look at the attachment.
So click on attachment list--
it takes you to that
attachment there.
Open it, and then there you go.
That's the image that you
just scanned and uploaded.
Yeah.
We wanted to get in
and show the process
for a different
invoice, as well.
Here is another
invoice, and I'll
try to quickly run through
so that you get a feeling of.
So this is the invoice.
Again, similar process.
Getting in, uploading
the invoice.
And you would see that--
this is a completely
different invoice,
with a completely
different format.
Again, we were able to upload
to the same application.
It's able to read.
It's able to understand.
So this was pretty much it.
This is really the
crux of the solution.
If you want to see
a live demo of it,
we are showing a live demo
offered in our Deloitte booth.
You're most welcome to come
in and then get a live look
and feel of how the
solution is looking.
So at this point of time, I
wanted to hand it over to Kirat
to conclude.
KIRAT PANDYA: Thank you Sudha.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
All right.
So, what did you just see?
You saw, in summary, we did
the three pieces, right?
We extracted the text.
We restructured
it back to a form
that is expected
by again tying it
all together to an existing
business process system.
So, the takeaway from all of
this is that the technology
you're seeing being announced
all around you here--
that's all ML, AI, oh my
god, it's the future--
it's real today.
You can connect the--
ML people like to do demos
like "hot dog, not hot dog"--
show you these abstract things.
And my goal here, if
you take away one thing,
is that this tech can be applied
to your existing business
process today.
All it takes is a little
creative thinking around, OK,
well, what is a painful
point that I deal
with every day that is either--
that either needs
lots of human people
doing a light touch sort
of "yes or no, yes or no?"
or is it just a very
step-through process
that just involves
understanding unstructured data.
Those kinds of problems
are solvable today.
You just have to sit down and
think about, "Wait a minute.
What if I were to apply
ML to this problem?
How would I solve it?"
[MUSIC PLAYING]